do you know what the most profitable
company in the world is most people
would probably guess apple and this
makes sense given that apple is one of
the most recognizable brands in the
entire world and they're usually the
largest company in the world as well but
Apple doesn't actually hold the title of
the most profitable company this title
actually goes to a background company
called Saudi aramco if you're not
familiar with Saudi aramco their Saudi
Arabia's Flagship oil company and
they've been at the top of the Fortune
500 for decades historically they've
often been the most profitable company
in the world but their profits over the
past 12 months are unlike anything we've
ever seen before by now I'm sure you're
well aware of the sky-high gas prices
around the world while things have
cooled down from their Peak a few months
ago prices are still pretty high on a
historical basis this has been terrible
news for everyday people who are just
trying to make end meet but for all
companies this has been a godsend at the
peak Saudi Arabia was profiting over a
billion dollars per day just from oil
exports and Saudi ronco's most recent
one month earnings stand at an
eye-watering
279 billion dollars for perspective this
is well over two times the Apple's
earnings of 120 billion dollars it's
also nearly as much as the profits of
Apple Google and Microsoft combined
something else to note is that it hasn't
even been one year since all prices
really became heated so as we close off
2022 Saudi aramco's rolling poem on the
profit should just balloon even higher
potentially to over 300 billion dollars
with that amount of money Saudi romco
could literally Buy Samsung with a
single check and still have a 30 billion
dollars left but things haven't always
been so Rosy for Saudi Arabia in fact
just a hundred years ago much of Saudi
Arabia was just a bunch bunch of tribes
were fighting for survival now you might
say that they just got lucky with oil
and while they did get lucky with their
natural resources that in itself is
nowhere near enough to build such an
Empire and if you don't believe me just
take a look at Venezuela who not only
has more oil than Saudi Arabia but
discovered their oil decades earlier you
would think that such a country would be
filthy rich but there are unfortunately
dirt poor and riddled with
hyperinflation the same thing could be
said about Canada as well who has the
world's third largest oil reserves
Canada is of course by no means doing
bad but given that they've been an
advanced country for far longer than
Saudi Arabia you would think that they
would have been able to capitalize on
their oil way more than Saudi Arabia yet
that's not the case so how did Saudi
Arabia become the winners of the oil
game
foreign
taking a look back Saudi Arabia was by
no means early to the oil game in fact
they were rather late and their entry
into oil wasn't particularly strategic
either it was more of Just A desperate
gamble in the decades preceding Saudi
Arabia searched for oil Saudi Arabia
wasn't even a thing instead the area was
controlled by two families called the
house of sauri and the house of Rashid
who were constantly in Conflict
sometimes the house of Saud would be on
top and other times the house of Rasheed
would be on top but there was really no
winner it was more or less just a big
Power struggle that led nowhere this
however would all change with the turn
of the century in the 1900s at the time
the rashidi family was on top and the
leader of the Saudi family abdulaziz
al-saud was an exile in Kuwait Abdul
hadn't forgotten about the house of
Rashid though and he was simply plotting
his counter-attack which would take
place in 1902 with this initial strike
Abdul would take back Riyadh which was
just the first of a series of of
conquests and before you knew it the
sauds were back in control the rashids
were forced into Exile just like the
sods previously but this was by no means
the end of it the Saudi family knew that
the rashidi family could strike back at
any time just like the sauds did so they
set out on advancing the area so much
that the rashidi family couldn't form a
counter-attack ironically this turned
out to be a non-issue given that the
rashidi family would dissolve in 1921
but the sauds didn't know that at the
time so they started working on creating
an unbeatable Force the first step in
this journey was to actually create an
official country this is what would
eventually lead to the birth of Saudi
Arabia in September of 1932. at this
point they officially had a country but
this didn't mean much without an economy
and unfortunately being surrounded by a
bunch of sand The Sounds didn't exactly
have a bunch of economical options in
fact they really only had it two options
option number one was to leverage their
access to the Sea they could build a
port or go pro diving or fish but this
is what they had already been doing for
Millennia troll diving in the Arabian
Peninsula literally dates back 7 000
years and given their current situation
it clearly wasn't all that profitable
option number two was to leverage their
religious significance Saudi Arabia was
and still is the home to Mecca which is
where millions of Muslims pilgrimage
every year but I suspect that the south
felt that leaning too much into religion
would have threaten their own power I
after all they've been destroying the
city ever since they took over in the
last 37 years or so Saudi Arabia has
demolished 95 percent of Mecca's
historical buildings so clearly becoming
an Islamic Vatican City wasn't a top
consideration with the sea and religion
crossed off as economic options Saudi
Arabia had to think outside the box and
it didn't take them long to take the oil
gamble just one year after the country
was formed Saudi Arabia would sign an
old concession agreement with the
Standard Oil Company of California or
SoCal for many years SoCal had little to
show for their efforts in Saudi Arabia
but eventually in 1938 Soca would strike
Liquid Gold
foreign
decades the vast majority of profits
from Saudi Arabia went to American
companies while Saudi Arabia was left
with a small dividend while this might
seem unfair at first glance there was
actually a lot of value for the sauds in
this partnership America might be the
ones that were left with the short-term
profits but with Saudi Arabia that was
left with the long-term Investments
scaling to millions of barrels per day
is by no means cheap and guess who
funded the cost the Americans access the
capital was not the only thing that the
Americans provided either they also
provided expertise that simply wasn't
available in Saudi Arabia at the time
for example in the 1940s the Americans
would help Saudi Arabia build a 1200
kilometer oil pipeline which was at the
time the longest in the world the
Americans also helped Saudi Arabia
identified the esophonia oilfield in
1951 which is the world's largest
offshore oil field to this day so while
America was hogging most of the profits
there were simultaneous honestly
building an empire an Empire that Saudi
Arabia could eventually take over Saudi
Arabia wasn't in any rush though while
their entrance into the oil industry was
kind of an accident they were determined
to be strategic with how they play their
cards moving forward a great example of
this was the formation of OPEC in 1960.
if you're not familiar with OPEC it's
basically an oil Union for oil producing
countries anyway it wasn't until the
1970s that Saudi Arabia finally began to
nationalize aramco Saudi aramco's
website likes to claim that Saudi Arabia
acquired ramcoa as opposed to
nationalizing the company The Story Goes
that the Saudi government bought a 25
stake in 1973 followed by 35 stake in
1974 and finally a 40 stake in 1980. I
guess this is technically a true but
it's unlikely that Saudi aramco paid
anywhere near market price for aramco
the acquisition price was never revealed
but experts estimated that it was likely
somewhere between one point 5 and 2
billion dollars even with inflation
that's only about 15 billion twenty
twenty two dollars for perspective the
company is now worth over two trillion
dollars and our production hasn't really
increased since the Americans left so
did the Americans get ripped off with
the acquisition probably but you can't
feel too bad for them given that they
had 40 years to exploit Saudi oil
undisturbed and with that Saudi Arabia
had officially taken over a romco
foreign
up to this point Saudi Arabia's Journey
isn't all that different from
Venezuela's Saudi Arabia essentially
called an exoner and let Exxon exploit
them for many decades before finally
taking over this is basically identical
to what the Venezuela did just with
shell instead of Exxon if anything
Venezuela was ahead of Saudi Arabia when
it came to finding oil and nationalizing
it so why did these two countries end up
on Polar ends of the spectrum well at
the end of the day it just all comes
down to management and strategy I know
most of us are not fans of authoritarian
regimes like Saudi Arabia but this is
one of the few cases in which being a
dictatorship actually helped the country
you see it Saudi Kings and princes were
always able to focus on the big picture
because they didn't have to worry about
selfish reasons as long as the country
was doing well their family would more
than likely keep control and become
extremely rich themselves the same
however could not be said about
Venezuelan leadership just because the
country does well 20 to 30 years from
now does not mean that their families
would also do well their time and power
was more than likely limited so they had
to make the most of it while they still
could
in other words they had to steal as much
as they could while they were still in
power this is why a hundred billion
dollars was embezzled by country
officials between 1972 and 1997 alone
and this is also why Venezuelan gold and
currency Reserve stand at just 10
billion dollars while Saudi Arabian
reserves stand at 473 billion dollars
aside from making long-term decisions
and saving up their money Saudi Arabia
also reinvested this money far more
effectively than Venezuela Saudi Arabia
used their money to build businesses
invest into the economy and recruit
International Talent this is why 85 of
Saudi engineers and 18 of Saudi CEOs are
actually expats Vision 2030 is also a
perfect example of this in the meantime
Venezuela was embracing socialism and
spending all of her money on social
programs and subsidizing various
everyday Goods so as Saudi Arabia was
becoming less dependent on oil Venezuela
was becoming more dependent on oil while
this is okay when Oilers strong the same
cannot be said when oil is weak and
that's exactly what happened in 2014
when oil prices crashed and the
Venezuelan economy collapsed while this
crash was not fun for Saudi Arabia
either they were able to comfortably
make it to the other side not because of
any one decision that they made during
the crash but because of Decades of
right decisions
today Saudi Arabia is one of the largest
companies in the world and it's usually
the most profitable now of course these
insane oil prices won't last forever and
that things will eventually cool down
hopefully this means that Saudi aranco's
profits will also cool down with the
time but really all this means for them
is profiting a hundred billion dollars
per year instead of 200 or 300 billion
zooming out to the long term the world
is slowly moving away from oil but this
will probably not impact Saudi Arabia
all that much given that they've been
slowly moving away from oil themselves
and to given that they've been playing
their cards extremely strategically ever
since they found oil I see no reason why
this will change in the coming decades
until then Saudi Arabia will remain as
one of the few countries in which an
authoritarian regime actually worked at
least economically if we're talking
socially that's a whole different story
but that's a topic for another video did
you realize how high Saudi aramco's
profits were common that down below also
drop a like if you hope that all prices
come down sooner rather than later and
of course consider checking out our
Discord Community to suggest future
video ideas and consider subscribing to
see more questions about you answered
but until then I'm Hari and I'll see you
guys on the next one